okay functional programming in pison I
was actually quite surprised that PI
data put me in into the big room I
thought functional programming that's an
old hat everybody's doing that nowadays
obviously it's still interesting
just very quickly about me I'm a data
scientist at EDA lab a small data
science consultancy and we mainly do
pison and I've only been doing pison for
two years now so I'm actually fairly new
to bison but I've done a lot of software
engineering in different languages I've
used Ruby JavaScript now also pison
Haskell and Swift and non-trivial
projects and I've played with closure
Scala elixir and Erlang so I've seen a
few things and I've given similar talks
on the topic of functional programming
in this specific language before for
example this one about JavaScript and
this talk will not be a motivation of
functional programming others have
already done that it's mainly a how-to
of how can you use functional
programming in pison there is a
disclaimer to this pison has a certain
philosophy pison is very approachable
because most of the concepts are very
very simple and many of the things I
will show you are kind of going against
that philosophy and that means or rather
I've forgotten this slide that goes so
far that in 25 in 2005 guida phone
awesome proposed to remove reduce from
the standard library it was not reduced
it was instead moved into the func tools
package but what what geetha said was
not having the choice streamlines the
thought process and that's something the
I very much disagree with I don't want
to have a language that forces me to
think in a certain way but rather I'd
like to have a language that supports me
when I solve a problem in my hat it
should be as easy as possible to
translate it at a high level into the
solution and for me functional
programming really does that and what I
hope to be doing is show the show you
the entrance to the rabbit hole and if
you want to go through it is your
decision and also for all the code here
I have Jupiter notebook that I will link
in the end and and it's really easy to
run it and play around yourself and also
don't hesitate to interrupt me if you
don't understand anything because none
of these concepts are difficult but you
are not used to them so they might seem
difficult at first so what we are going
to do is to now kind of build a
vocabulary of concepts that we need to
look at some yeah pretty easy but
slightly more complex examples and
functional programming involves quite a
few concepts we'll go through a few of
them not all of them mainly the ones
that I need to show you examples of
course purity is a big concept in
functional programming it's not that
important for us now but just so you've
seen this once what is a pure function
it's a function without side effects and
the function at the top clearly has no
side effects you put arguments in get a
result out that's it and the function
below clearly modifies a global variable
which is often not what you should do
it's much easier to think about these
clean small pure functions first-class
functions
that sounds strange but it simply means
that functions are like everybody else
and in Python we have that which enables
us to do a lot of the cool stuff we can
define functions as normally with a def
statement we have also these lambda
expressions and we can use the names of
the functions as variables we can assign
them to different variables and that
also means we can do higher-order
programming and that means we have a
function that takes another function as
an argument and might again return a
function there's something we can easily
do in pison in this example we have like
these functions are sometimes called
Combinator we have a Combinator that
takes a function and wraps it into a
timing functionality and after this
function we actually want to call is
done it prints how long it took okay but
we already know that if you've used
decorators that's exactly what they do
so even if you don't know functional
programming many of you have already
used it in the form of decorators
another very important concept in
functional programming is partial
function application and now it's
becoming slightly more fancy but it's
also something that's having been sort
of in pison versus a package called hung
tools and it includes this partial
function but quickly back to the example
I might have a function that takes many
arguments and what I want to have is a
function where I already applied one of
the arguments in this add example I
might want to have this add one function
I can simply define it with a def
statement add one I get the function
that I'd like to have but what I also
can use is this power
combinator which simply takes the
function and some arguments that I want
to partially apply and what I get back
is a function where the remaining
arguments are not yet applied so I can
call it with the remaining arguments and
get a result back so these are of course
really toy examples I mean who wants the
add one function nobody but we will see
that having this possibility of
partially applying functions is really
powerful and with with partial
application also comes a concept of
currying and it's sometimes a little bit
confusing what's currying what's
partially applying and wikipedia says
about currying it's transforming a
function that takes multiple arguments
in such a way that it can be called as a
chain of functions each with a single
argument partial application and that's
really what carrying is so it's in a way
the dual concept to partial applications
it creates form a normal function you
can create through carrying it a
function that can be much easier
partially applied and we can manually
kuryak function in by by wrapping it in
this way we have this binary function
again at and we just define a new
function that takes the first argument
and return a new function that takes the
second argument to apply both so again
it's it's not a fancy concept it's
really simple in a way and if we of
course only apply the first argument we
get a function back if we apply both
arguments we get the result back now
this doesn't really look nice the good
thing is there are libraries out there
that enable you to just curry any
function so we have this curry
Combinator
and if we call it we also have don't
have to use this double braces anymore
but we can just call a function with an
argument and then get back a function
that waits for the rest of the arguments
and a really important concept for
currying is closures because why does
this work it seems like when returning
this inner function it somehow remembers
this argument from the outer function
this a and that is called lexical
scoping so each function carries with it
the scope in which it was defined and it
remembers the variables and if it's
being called it just can look up in that
scope where it was defined and basically
every language that has closures
supports a lot of functional programming
concepts and currying is really not that
Akane there are actually in the standard
library examples of functions that use
currying there's this module called
operator which includes a lot of the
operators you normally use for
arithmetic slike plus multiplication
division as functions but what it also
contains is these item get her a
together and method caller and those are
in a way constructs to enable you giving
you curried constructs like when you
want to call a method on an object you
could instead also use this method
caller first call it was only the name
of the method and that gives you a
curried function that waits for an
object to apply that method on that is
kind of abstract now but I'll have an
example in a moment and what's also very
important in functional programming is
these functional collection
transformations and there
basically the three most important which
are met map filter and reduce and I want
to just quickly show them and show the
equivalent as a list comprehensions
because I guess you are using list
comprehensions all the time and maybe
not the functional equivalents so this
concept of applying a function to every
element of a sequence or iterator is
called map and below this map function
call is the equivalent as a list
comprehension the filter function takes
a predicate which is a function that
returns true or false for some argument
and with filter you can filter an
iterator and only get back the elements
that return true for the predicate and
in list comprehension so you can simply
you can simply attach an if statement at
the end and yeah call your predicate
there and there is then there is this
kind of final boss in functional
collection transformations which is
reduce where people often say oh I don't
understand what it is and the thing is
it's not not that hard especially if you
see the equivalent and the argument
often goes like hey why don't you write
out the loop if you can do it and it's
much more easy to understand but I don't
see why this argument really counts and
in that same article that I told you
about where ghido phone Rossum proposed
to remove we would use HEAF he's written
almost every time I see a reduced call
with a non-trivial function argument I
need to grab pen and paper to diagram
what's actually being fed into that
function before I understand that to
reduce what the reduce is supposed to do
so I've done that now once and for all
if you want to grab pen and
paper you don't need to anymore because
this is what reduced us and I just
quickly want to go through it with you
so a reduce turns a single object this
square and a list of objects those are
the circles with the help of a binary
function that takes one Square one
circle into a single Square and it does
it by simply taking the square thing and
the first circle applying the function
getting a new Square and then repeating
that over and over until there are no
circles left and that's reduce it's so
simple another very important concept is
function composition and for example
when you're doing a list comprehension
where you apply a function and apply a
predicate to a filter then what you're
actually doing is composing two
functions you first run a filter then
run a map and we could express it a
little bit differently and here I'm
already using this currying
functionality so I could just say hey
compose these two functions the first
function is filter partially applied
with this predicate so filter P just
means I have a function that filters
based on this predicate so it awaits
still the collection to be put in and
the map is the same thing it's just a
function that's preloaded with this
function it wants to apply to a list
that is not yet applied and if we
compose these two functions we get
exactly the same thing we first filter
thank than map and that's it so let's
look at our first a little more complex
example a Betsy as V parser maybe we
don't know about pandas maybe palace is
Rubick was not available so we have this
CSV as a text and we want to get out
these kind of records a list of
dictionaries and this is kind of a very
simple imperative Python example I mean
what would you do you split on the new
lines then for each line you split on
the semicolons then you get the first
line out which is supposed to act as the
keys for the dictionaries and then for
each row in that matrix kind of object
you just build the dictionary by first
yeah you have this empty records array
and you for each line you append a new
record okay looks good looks easy now
this could be a functional equivalent
and first of all you might say oh
there's so much going on it's it's
strange the imperative example is much
more easily to digest but if you get
into functional programming and I'll
explain what these blocks are doing in a
moment then it's in my opinion much
easier to to grasp on a high level very
correctly what a what a what an
algorithm is supposed to be doing so
what we are doing here is at first of
course we are importing a lot of stuff
because pison is not really meant to be
used functional functionally and you
probably recognized i'm also importantly
sinkhole tools and that is nowadays when
i'm doing a private person project
always the first thing that i import
because it provides me with a lot of
useful functions like already curried
versions of compose and map and then i'm
using partial and method color light
like i said before and now the second
block is actually very interesting what
I'm doing there is I'm building from
these very simple functions that I have
slightly more complicated but still
very very simple functions I'm building
from little tools slightly bigger tools
like because the split function on
strings is it's not really in a form
like I would have wanted it to have I'm
using a partial application on method
caller and then with this split function
I can build functions that split on
certain separators for example split
lines is just split on new line split
fields is just split on semicolon what I
also want to have because I want to
build the same matrix that we saw in the
other example is a function that can
build a dictionary from an array of keys
and an array of values and that is
simply composed dict and zip so dict is
the datatype dictionary but it's also a
function so I can simply compose it with
other functions zip is a function that
given two lists of equal lengths gives
me back a new list with pairs for each
index in the lists
Rissa right elements and with this
output dict can work I can give ticked a
list of pairs and get a dictionary so
take from crease and veldt's is just
this functions that are composed out of
two Zimmer's simpler functions and then
in the end oh yeah first of all they see
if v2 metrics is just the thing that
gives me this list of lists of strings
into a matrix and once I finally have
all these small tools I can really build
on a very high level my program and
first of all I want to pull everything
out into this list of lists then I pull
out the first row of those lists as the
keys and then I map over
the rest of the rows with a function
that builds a dictionary that is this
partial dict from keys and wealth keys
that is already preloaded with the keys
everybody understands what's going on I
I have a I have a Jupiter notebook and I
can in the interactive tile if it in the
interactive part if you want go through
these parts a little more in detail
another example is PI spark and I think
I've seen like four or five sessions and
about PI spark during this PI data and
here I don't want to go into any detail
but just draw your attention to these
functions at the bottom this map and
reduce and if you have never never
worked with wisp iceberg but come from a
functional background and look at the
API of rdd's then you will feel right at
home because both are just all the
functional collection transformations
that you expect so if you learn
functional programming you can basically
already work with spark okay
I have a second expand example that I
would not go into tema too much detail
because of time constraints but I wanted
to have it in here I stole it from
someone who had a great talk about
itertools at a pilot a conference in in
Seattle and if you know k-means or
rather if you know the Lloyd algorithm
which is a version of k-means and you
see this you will definitely say okay
yeah that is how K means works in
k-means you iterate finding new means
and you're feeding in an initial sample
of K points at the initial means and you
do that until this converges and this
really is for me the essence of
functional programming
it's very high-level functions composed
of smaller functions and if you just
look at the main algorithm you should be
able to see and understand and read at a
high level what it does and here I would
say I definitely do and one one other
cool thing is that a lot of these
functions like this until conversion its
convergence has nothing to do with
k-means it's just a very general
function that helps me if I have an
iterator run it until it doesn't change
anymore and give me the result back and
here's the rest of the code it's also in
the notebook it's using some currying of
course to make things easier but what
are the main takeaways here I mean we've
seen functional programming is possible
in pison to a degree and what I hope
that you've also seen is that small
composable functions are good no matter
if you're using a functional style or an
imperative style but for me functional
programming is exactly that build
general tools and then compose them and
that makes solving problems at least for
me much easier but pison is also missing
a few things at least for me especially
coming from a language like Hasker there
there's itertools which is useful but
there are more functions that that are
really useful and they are not in the
standard library also the lambda syntax
is not really nice you've seen me only
use it once in these slides
and especially if you if you want to use
something like an if statement in a
lambda which you can't you have to go
for the ternary operator and I mean then
it becomes to reduce with the lambda and
the ternary operator is unreadable also
something that we of course don't have
is automatic carrying and a nice
composition syntax I have to use this
long compose function and then there are
a few other things like jariabek
datatypes or some types and pattern
matching which we don't have in pi scene
but there are some remedies first of all
others have written these more list
functions that I complained about PI
tools is the one that I chose for this
presentation also that I use personally
then there's another one called FN pi
which really looks good and I haven't
worked with pi functional but just from
glossing over what there it also looked
good
the first one by the way PI tools is by
MSE Rocklin who gave a keynote of last
year's PI data Berlin in this in the
second library there's an interesting
construct that kind of provides a nicer
lambda syntax and if you've done spark
you know the syntax with this underscore
but it's it's a strange construct and
it's kind of fragile I try to use it in
when playing with PI spark and it didn't
work at all and there's other
interesting stuff that others have done
in pison so there are just a few links
if you're interested in this topic then
yeah go down that route yeah just smash
it it's a good idea and those are other
talks about functional for AMA
programming in Python the wave stole
some material there's good stuff out
there and also
the end my own talk about JavaScript
you'll see striking similarities to that
previous talk that first one is actually
by Matthew Rocklin and it's it's a
tutorial on Python functional
programming it goes a few a little bit
deeper in a few of those concepts the
second one is by the author of F n dot
PI yeah and the third one is really good
it's it doesn't use any of these
functional programming libraries but
just shows what you can do just with
itertools
and if you want to go deeper into
functional programming I actually
haven't read the structure of interpret
and interpretation of computer
programming but everybody recommends it
so I have to recommend into but I have
read big parts of the other two books
about Haskell and really Haskell is the
gateway drug to get into functional
concepts it's a really cool cool
language so thank you
that was my talk I think I'm quite good
on the time we have time for questions
do we have people with mics going around
I see hands
hi I'm Great Auk thanks for that so I
think you left out one of the most
important pain points you had it on the
on the intro slide and it was striped
out but it wasn't in the missing that
was the immutability and i would love to
have that in python so not seeing it on
missing kind of implies to me that do
you have a workaround I'd be really
interested in in immutability yeah so of
course you don't have it per se but what
people have done is create immutable
data structures functional immutable
data structures so that if you have
something like a ticket or something
like a list so that you can modify it I
mean that just a matter of implementing
a data structure that prevents you from
doing these harmful things so yes people
have done that
and I think it was on this what other
people have done slight yeah exactly so
there there really is no construct for
that and of course you you just have to
not do it yeah there's nothing that
forces you to avoid side effects or even
just avoid mutating State so sorry for
that
so a great talk when it comes to
programming Java in Python is one of
rare instances when javascript is
cleaner way cleaner because we can
change things like filters maps etc and
for me the biggest pain point in Python
is that this composition of filter and
map is ugly and you cannot go it within
like six themes and make it commercially
comprehensible so is there any
workaround
it's not so in this F n dot pi there's
another interesting construct which is
in kind of a function that's just called
F they call it a functional and you can
use that to wrap functions and that
gives you a slightly lies a nicer
composition syntax but the main point
here is definitely it's ugly because we
don't have a nice composition syntax if
we had that it would reach much better
we now we have to put this compose and
then in parantesis and then all the
functions as arguments it's not that
nice in in Haskell you simply use a dot
and then it's really really well
readable
maybe this construct in FN dot pi is a
solution maybe it makes things harder to
debug I'm not sure I haven't used it but
you might want to have a look at FN dot
pi there was a hand in the front here
from a gentleman that
very nice talk I just think we can walk
about this pure function you you show
this add function and you say this would
be an example for pure function but you
can already assume it you if you
overload the plus and you don't know
what a and B is oh that would be a side
effect yeah that's true yeah so yeah
that there's in in Haskell you really
have the possibility to separate pure
and non pure code because it's actually
encoded in the type system so pison is a
dynamic language type system is not an
option I've seen a library oh yeah it's
on the slides here somebody's doing
something on the separation of side
effects and pure code I haven't looked
at this but maybe that would be
something interesting for you yeah
thanks for your talk I just wanted to
ask about what sir concerns about the
underscore construct in my spark yeah so
in in PI spark the code is mostly not
running on your machine and you you send
it off and you have to make sure that
you serialize everything and this
serialization failed in the experiments
that I made there are some instructions
in the PI spark documentation on how you
have to package up your code so that
basically everything get can get
properly serialized
I didn't really try to find out what was
wrong I just quickly tried it use this
construct instead of a normal lambda
didn't see realize I thought okay not
for me but it might work somehow but you
have to find out how you can can be sure
that all the code you need for this
construct is actually on the distant
machine and properly serializable and D
serializable
yeah it kind of is differ different
because the lambda function is yeah it's
a language construct and this underscore
was yeah library that I imported from
somewhere so there's a lot of code from
somewhere else involved so I'm not I'm
not sure how cloud pickles he realizes
stuff but it somehow has to walk the
abstract syntax tree and find out where
was stuff imported from I would guess so
I can't really give a good answer to
that sorry
thanks for the talk so basically I come
from a scallop background and then going
to pies pies Park feels a little bit
clumsy in the sense that you don't have
many of the mutts like you don't have
the option manner and you don't have
either so I want to know if there's any
of these packages that actually try to
mimics that and if you had use it in
production thank you yeah of course
maybe was also some of the things that I
was instantly looking for and I haven't
found anything that it's pretty people
are trying to do it what's really really
clumsy and I've seen nothing that's
worth the effort
so I think I have to disappoint you but
maybe somebody else has seen something
that's actually good I haven't so far
she's gonna play here the part of the
devil's advocate I was looking at your
code and I I mean I work with functional
programming scholarly a bit and when I
saw Yuko I think if I see that in a
really long source code gonna get super
confused and I also read recently that
for example they recommend to use this
comprehension instead of mapping what
you're like generating new data from a
list because it's more readable and is
even faster so I wanna know your take on
that
in how to violence reliability and
maintainability because with that if you
just write code in that manner you can
end up with like they design a spaghetti
code yeah I'm not sure I really have a
good answer on that I mean a big
argument against functional programming
is that it's confusing but is it if you
do it all the time that it becomes less
confusing and we are learning new
libraries all the time so why can't we
learn these concepts and get really
fluent in them but pison has this
certains philosophy and like I don't
really want to fight with that and
that's also the reason why I don't
recommend doing this what I've done here
and also you're right for sums of some
of the codes I've I've used here I've
really done functional programming with
a crowbar I think a healthy mix is a
good idea for example this example that
I stole and modified slightly this is a
main function and it's really functional
and to my opinion it's really well
readable and when you go down into the
function then you see okay there are
actually a lot of list comprehensions
and like more idiomatic pison and i
think they have no argument against that
but I really think it helps to on a high
level has a more have a more functional
style because to me it's better
understandable it's it's more readable
it if you do it well it reads like
English and we have time for one more
question
yes thanks for allowing me this last
question
so and have you already taken a look at
hi because I think that would be the
perfect solution for you it's a lisp
dialect for Python which directly
translates Lisp syntax to Python
abstract syntax trees without much
overhead and it has all those features
you need like function compositions and
create lambda lambda functions and all
that stuff so it's working it's it's a
bit like closure in its syntax taya I
think we are gonna talk after this
presentation I think you like okay so of
course the the big argument for pison
especially in data science is that we
have all these nice these nice libraries
like pandas and scikit-learn
and being able to talk to those
libraries from something that has yeah
better language features would be for me
and i think so
thank you
you